[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue en ce 7 8
sport sur tv 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
course à pied après plusieurs reports
l'eco trail de paris est parti ce samedi
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines
au programme 1 80 km jusqu'à paris
reportage à suivre football coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur un
footballeur heavy noie son nom christian
gomis le joueur originaire de
vernouillet est aujourd'hui l'une des
stars du lokomotiv bloc dif un club de
première division bulgare nous l'aurons
avec nous dans ce set vite sport
équitation direction l'hippodrome de
rambouillet la structure créée à la fin
du 19e siècle accueille neuf réunions
par an et des centaines de chevaux
présentation du site dans ce à magazine
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par de la
course à pied après plusieurs reports
l'eco trail de paris ile de france s'est
finalement tenue ce samedi 3 juillet
avec un départ depuis l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines pour le à
80 km les organisateurs ont dû s'adapter
pour cette première édition depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire des images
de bixente mérian santisteva il
attendait cela depuis deux ans et demi
après plusieurs reports mille six cent
cinquante coureurs ont pris le départ du
80 km de l'eco trail paris ile de france
est forcément les sourires étaient
présents sur les visages des
participants sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines et ça fait un
moment qu'on attendait tous à quoi donc
c'est vrai que bon bah ouais c'est la
première grande course morale tombe
l'été alors que l'eco trail d'habitude
on est sur le mois de mars
mais ouais c'est avec plaisir qu'on
comprend un coureur qu'on va retrouver
des sensations
pour pouvoir organiser cette 14e édition
les organisateurs ont dû s'adapter face
à la crise sanitaire
les cours ont rendu notamment partir par
vagues a été une organisation différente
cette année puisqu'en fait on a fait sur
plusieurs départs avec
des modalités liées aux circonstances
sanitaires on est très content les
coureurs en jeu le jeu au niveau de
l'organisation ça s'est très bien passé
des bénévoles pour toujours enthousiaste
donc on est vraiment super content de
pouvoir être de retour
le parcours lui est resté inchangé les
trailer sont notamment passés par
montigny le bretonneux bullock ou encore
vélizy villacoublay en direction de la
tour eiffel il a un dénivelé qui est
relativement
praticable ça n'est pas de l'ultra-trail
mais ça permet quand même de pouvoir
traverser toute l'île de france dans des
conditions qui sont assez spectaculaires
puisque on veut aller jusqu'à versailles
on peut voir des dvd des paysages qui
sont vraiment très diversifié on n'est
pas à la montagne
on est quand même dans un éco trade les
meilleurs en terminer les 80 km en 5
heures et 39 minutes sur le pont d'iéna
la 15e édition de cette course devrait
être programmée en mars prochain
on va maintenant à parler un football
coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur un
footballeur yvelinois son nom à
christian gomis le joueur originaire de
vernouillet est aujourd'hui l'une des
stars du lokomotiv plovdiv un club de
première division bulgare nous avons la
chance de l'avoir avec nous dans cette
émission le défenseur central de 22 ans
bonsoir question gomis bonsoir
alors tout on va commencer déjà par à
part votre parcours du coup dans ce
championnat bulgare qu comment ça se
passe actuellement en bulgarie
expliquez-nous franchement à l'heure
actuelle ça se passe super moment bien
là on a fini deuxième du classement
devant 16 cas sociaux nous apprêtons à
discuter les barrages de l'europa league
et franchement je me plais décor est
alors vous avez été formé pendant de
nombreuses années dans les yvelines
racontez nous un petit peu votre
parcours j'ai commencé le football dans
le club de ma ville de vernon id
ensuite j'ai joué à verneuil juste à
côté et pour ensuite jouer aux mureaux
donc qui situe pas très loin aussi
et ensuite après ça a commencé à partir
ce parti au psg et après le psg j'ai
fait certaines aventures
j'ai commencé à partir à pacy sur eure
en normandie
ensuite j'ai été en italie c'était en
l'an 2000 17 ans c'est bien ça de sa
part exacte et j'ai pris ma première
expérience en italie
du coup j'ai malheureusement j'ai fait
que six mois car si c'est pas trop
certainement en série d un c'est bien ça
exactement
c'était quand vous n'en 200 série c'est
en séries puis par van
après sûr je suis parti à bastia étoile
filante en corse pour terminer notre
partie de saison comme j'ai fait qu six
mois en italie et l'année d'après je
retourne au pg votre pg pour un an mais
avec la compétition avec toute la saison
a été stoppée mi février
du coup ça fait que c'est pas étendre
jouer de montrer ce que je valais et
tout donc voilà après j'étais sans club
et moi la bulgarie alors aujourd'hui au
lokomotiv plongez vous avez 22 ans est
ce que c'est un petit peu un parcours du
combattant
si je peux dire votre parcours
combattants oui ça va ça va fait grandir
ses différentes aventures ce que pour un
garçon de 22 ans j'ai pas mal voyagé pas
mal bougé ou du coup mais je suis fier
d'avoir fait tout ça alors de georges et
c'est ce qui me fait grandir est ce que
vous pensez qu'on a plus sa chance à
l'étranger
peut-être qu'en france vous tirer un peu
il parce qu'en france il ya tellement
dur que certains sont oubliés dont loi
donc du coup il est préférable de faire
son trou à l'étranger pour ensuite
revenir en france dans les années à
venir
est ce que le fait de partir à
l'étranger ça vous a permis de grandir
aussi vous personnellement et en temps
de footballeur franchement mentalement
surtout j'ai beaucoup grandi le fait
d'être seul
ils sont ma famille m m livre à moi même
qu à ça m'a fait grandir et ça m'a rendu
plus autonome justement comment réagit
votre entourage quand vous leur avez dit
je vais à signer dans un club en en
bulgarie franchement tout mon entourage
n'étaient pas choqués parce qu'ils
savent que j'ai un voyageur et j'ai pas
prendre la voiture
il était très fier de moi et en espérant
que cette aventure sur la bonne longueur
justement depuis votre arrivée vous êtes
titulaire on peut le dire vous avez
remplacer un joueur blessé et depuis
vous ne sortez plus du onze de départ ça
se passe bien
du coup dans ce club de bulgarie si ça
se passe bien j'attendais juste ma
chance pour la saisir je travaille à
fond noir et même sur le terrain pendant
les entraînements en dehors du terrain
donc du coup j'attendais juste elle
chance-là pouvoir la saisir et je les
fait et voilà
est-ce que vous en avez surpris
quelques-uns au club franchement oui
vous allez franchement eu carrément tout
et puis est arrivé sur la pointe des
pieds
malgré mon jeune âge professionnelle
mais mes coéquipiers étaient un peu plus
surpris de me voir à ce niveau là
maintenant quel est le niveau du
championnat bulgare comparé aux
championnats de france par exemple quel
type de jeu si pratique là bas je dirais
que ce ne fut guère est l'équivalent la
ligue 2 et bah mon équipe le lokomotiv
plovdiv on peut jouer aux tables en
ligue 2 je pense alors on l'a enfin vous
l'avez dit précédemment le cska sofia a
terminé derrière vous c'est le club
phare un petit peu en bulgarie comment
se constitue votre club est ce que c'est
un club en devenir
est ce que c'est un club qui peut être
l'un des maillons forts du championnat
sur les prochaines années
oui mais franchement oui à tout ce qu'il
faut pour réussir ici il ya des bons
joueurs les entraîneurs c'est bien
encadré et c'est franchement laid ce
club et linteau pour devenir parmi les
meilleurs en bulgarie alors vous avez
encore un an de contrat dans ce club de
plovdiv
est-ce que vous allez rester encore
pendant pendant un an ou vous comptez
peut-être partir au mercato bat
honnêtement moi je terminais ma saison
apprend c'est parce qu'il peut se passer
mais je compte terminer la saison j'aime
bien aller au bout de mes contrats
et là c'est ce que je suis en train de
faire pour l'instant elle apprendra sans
moment m ce qui m'a même proposé
on sait qu'on peut discuter à partir de
janvier avec un autre club
est ce que un retour en france pourrait
être envisageable
mais franchement pourquoi pas si j'ai
l'opportunité de revenir en france ce
serait toujours un plaisir prend ça
serait aussi
lytro en revanche car j'ai été un beau
but on va dire et si je peux revenir en
france moi ça serait top est-ce que vous
avez un club peut-être en france qui
vous fait rêver sur lequel vous dans
lequel vous aimeriez évolué non plus
tout non j'aime bien et comme en france
j'ai été formé au psg donc c'est le fief
des gènes sinon après apparemment j'ai
aimé tous les autres clubs aussi ça me
dérange pas comme ligue 1 ligue 2
n'importe quoi tout le monde s'arrête
professionnels
est-ce que vous rêvez d'aller dans un
club en particulier je crois que vous
avez beaucoup le championnat italien
exactement je grand fin de la jeune fils
de de çi et j'aimerais évoluer
et qu'est ce qui vous plaît justement à
la juventus de turin
j'aime beaucoup la tactique et qui met
en place et l'amour des supporters c'est
ce que ce que j'aime le plus inspiré de
certains joueurs ou pas à la juventus de
turin
je sais que dans votre rôle par exemple
il ya le fameux chiellini qui joue en
défense centrale est ce que parce que
vous inspirez lui mais quand même j'aime
beaucoup qui les unit sinon je suis
j'aime beaucoup du ballon et là j'ai
actuellement un ami qui joue aussi à la
juventus des aides aux skis ou ce qui me
fait rire encore plus donc c'est
envisageable à transfert à la juventus
peut-être dans les prochaines années
franchement oui c'est ce que je souhaite
j'espère il combien de temps vous donnez
du coup pour pour accomplir ce rêve
franchement d'ici trois quatre années
mon cher alors dernière question plus
personnelle vous êtes originaire de
vernouillet on l'a dit a précédemment
est-ce que vous revenez de temps en
temps dans votre ville franchement je
reviens le plus souvent possible dernier
c'est ma ville c'est ce qui m'a fait
grandir et je suis là aussi pour
représenter ma ville
car elle manque un peu de lumière et je
suis là pour représenter leur nid merci
à vous à christian gomis on vous
souhaite d'avoir une très belle carrière
et pourquoi pas aller un jour à la
juventus de turin merci beaucoup et on
continuera à vos idéaux avec attention
en tout cas passé merci beaucoup
alors on va maintenant parler des jeux
olympiques antoine runner le
pensionnaire du golf de la boulie à
versailles a appris une très bonne
nouvelle elle était retenue pour
participer avec l'équipe de france aux
jeux olympiques de tokyo cet été ce sera
une grande première pour ce golfeur et
binoy qui performe depuis plusieurs
semaines en europe et aux états unis il
avait notamment battu en 1 contre 1 le
numéro cinq mondial brayden 2 chambaud
il a réagi sur les réseaux sociaux
il a partagé sa fierté à sur les réseaux
et entente rare de la voir à son retour
du japon pour avoir ces à réaction lui
aussi sera présent aux jeux olympiques
de tokyo en judo à 34 ans guillaume
chaîne participera à ses premiers jo
après avoir été remplaçant en 2016 à rio
le judoka espère faire briller son club
de sartrouville au niveau international
dans la catégorie des moins de 73 kg un
reportage de bixente mérian santisteva
et justine brazy guillaume chaîne aura
sa chance aux jeux olympiques est 2021
remplace en 2016 à rio le judoka de
sartrouville pourra cette fois foulé les
tatamis de la plus prestigieuse des
compétitions
une fierté à bientôt 35 ans si je dois
revenir 3,4 en arrière je me rouiller
peut-être pas continuer jusque jusqu'aux
jeux olympiques mais comme je le répète
souvent on arrive à se ré fixer des
objectifs et ce challenge et tous les
joueurs donc petit à petit je me suis
rapproché de l'objectif et j'ai vraiment
commencé à y croire
le report des jeux aurait été pour
guillaume shell l'occasion de bien
travailler son judo basé sur le comics
atta les prises de kimonos le français
s'envolera bientôt vers tokyo avec un
objectif clair l'objectif comme chacun
des athlètes qui se présente aux jeux
olympiques j'espère pour eux c'est
d'aller décrocher l'or maintenant moi
c'est mes premiers jeux olympiques donc
c'est déjà une petite victoire en soit
maintenant j'y vais pas pour figurer non
plus guillaume l'a déjà prouvé
par le passé il est capable de battre
les meilleurs et d'aller au bout de vos
bouts de pas mal de compétition donc on
verra bien le jour j en soutien à
guillaume chaîne et au judo club est la
mairie de sartrouville votre à une
subvention de 10000 euros lors de son
prochain conseil municipal pour être
performant pour s'entraîner pour pour
entraîner les plus jeunes
voilà il ya besoin d'eux
on a besoin de matériel on a besoin de
partir en stage
voilà tout ça c'est un coup on note donc
on a besoin de moyens avec un grand
plaisir qu'on accepte l'aide de la
mairie et et j'espère que voilà ça ça
contre il contribuera à beaucoup à de
belles choses pour le club
guillaume chaîne étant contrats
entendent encore un an qu'au judo de
sartrouville
il n'exclut pas une prolongation au club
aujourd'hui classé parmi les 10
meilleurs de france direction à présent
rambouillet la vie la ville abrite en
bordure de sa forêt l'un des plus grands
hippodromes d'île de france depuis la
fin du 19e siècle coup de projecteur en
montage de lucas audard au coeur de la
forêt de rambouillet sur un site de 40
hectares depuis plus d'un siècle les
passionnés de courses hippiques peuvent
assister à des manifestations sur cet
hippodrome historique
le lieu a organisé ses premières courses
en 1890 avec des tribunes en bois autour
de la piste
c'était si vous voulez des courses
familial et amical
y'avait pas du tout dangereux comme on a
aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui on allait
on a les jeux qui sont faits sur
l'hippodrome à l'époque c'était plutôt
des ce qu'on appelle des courses de
jantes lohman c'étaient des amis qui se
rencontraient et qu'il courait après des
décennies de courses l'hippodrome est
devenu un lieu réservé aux
professionnels le site organise neuf
réunions chaque année entre avril et
octobre
depuis 1991 l'hippodrome se consacre
uniquement à la spécialité du trot il
est passé en première catégorie en
janvier 2019
ça veut dire qu'on a des si vous voulez
des écuries des grandes écuries qui vont
à vincennes et ailleurs vienne courait
aussi et on a des gains plus importants
des courses là maintenant on a vraiment
les deux rives heures qui viennent
les river de paris qui viennent courir
en vie l'hippodrome est aujourd'hui
considéré comme l'un des plus beaux en
france sa piste en 1 fait 1800 mètres
avec une corde à gauche
sa largeur et 2 50 mètres ce dimanche 20
juin l'enceinte sportif est encore
l'unanimité auprès des drivers les tops
ya rien à dire
c'est une excellente piste il n'y a pas
de piège c'est souvent le meilleur
cheval qui gagne donc voilà les super
bien entretenu c'est des grands virages
des grandes heures de départ non c'est
le top on a aussi bien installé 15
années en dehors des courses
l'hippodrome de rambouillet se veut
également être un lieu de vie à chaque
réunion des centaines de personnes
peuvent participer à des animations
autour de l'équitation organisé par les
trois bénévoles du site
une grande salle de paris de 300 m² est
ouverte pendant la manifestation les
visiteurs peuvent en parallèle approcher
au plus près les professionnels et les
115 chevaux présents à chaque rendez
vous je pense que même les plus petits
sont très contents de regarder les
chevaux en plus ici sur l'hippodrome de
rambouillet le chaque personne peut
aller se balader dans les stalles aller
rencontrer les chevaux aller les voir
prendre leur douche aller parler aux
propriétaires et poser toutes les
questions qu'ils veulent
le seul endroit où et on ne peut pas
marcher c'est sur la piste en selle pour
le spectacle les prochaines courses à
rambouillet sont programmées en
septembre sur l'hippodrome un mot de
voile on l'a appris la semaine dernière
après sa cinquième place sur dix au
cyanure ace europe c'est officiel louis
burton participera à la transat jacques
vabre le skipper originaire de
rambouillet tentera de rallier le port
du havre à salvador de bahia au brésil
pour cela il sera accompagné une
nouvelle fois de davy beaudart les deux
marins embarqueront sur le nouveau
bateau bureau vallée trois dernières
fois le duo avait terminé à la 10e place
la 15e édition partira le 7 novembre
prochain en apnée andy cabreira avila la
playlist franco-cubain de saint cyr
l'école a réussi un nouveau défi la
parcours où 52 km en apnée en remontant
à la surface entre hyères et ses îles
pour sensibiliser à la cause des océans
il a réalisé ce périple entre le 5 et le
11 juin chaque fois le sportif de 50 ans
a plongé à une profondeur de deux mètres
pour amasser plusieurs kilos de déchets
nous avons andy cabreira avait là avec
nous à distance bonsoir
bonsoir chanter alors pourquoi avoir
voulu réaliser ce défi en 10 alors est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé de
tout ça c'est justement prochain suivi
lycée tous les publics surtout les
enfants à eau déchets qui traînent dans
le sien qui polluent aussi et surtout à
la mer méditerranée qui est ce la paire
la plus polluée au monde
donc voilà l'objectif est de
sensibiliser et de participer à un
massage et on a fait avec d'autres
associations dans laquelle on a partagé
ce défi c'était l'occasion de la journée
mondiale des océans c'est bien ça sera
oui alors comment ça s'est passé ce défi
expliquez nous alors les filles
président il l'avait fait à la piscine
là c'est un défi inédit réalisé au maire
donc à la piscine à saint cyr l'école en
le précisant la logistique c'est par là
même et on était trente cinq personnes à
1,4 voilier un catamaran de ce diack un
kayak donc en train de ramener sa
sécurité pour garantir la sécurité de
tous les parcours adore alors on est
partis de l'idée hier ensuite les de
porquerolles port-cros l'île du levant
l'effort des vi nations et on a fini à
la lande et moi à chaque parcours je
nageais sur leur apnée j'ai sauté pour
respirer et on arrivera à chaque vive
après on organise et rend ramassage des
déchets et c'est incroyable de voir tous
les déchets est éteint quand même des
fois un mètre carré ont ramassé des
dessins des dessins des des bouteilles
de plastique des quantités et plastiques
minuscule qui sont vraiment coupé en
morceaux et à quel prix et les poissons
une image après nous manger aussi les
pots sont évidemment toute la chaîne
alimentaire est contaminée par les
plastiques et quels sont les déchets
vous avez le plus trouvé en mer et
sachets des sacs en plastique scellé
plus parce que 1,5 en plastique est
décomposée en mille morceaux et après
d'un incident de la médiane et on a
l'approché doni il se mélange avec les
sags
c'est très difficile à trier les
plastiques et voilà conforme à surpasser
sa menace à semaine dans les salles de 7
difficile donc des sacs en plastique des
bouteilles en plastique les deux et pour
vous l'avez fait spécifiquement sur ce
lieu à part hier et c6 r et cécile
d'abord parce que c'est un endroit
protégé ça veut dire que les styles des
port cros et surtout les packs national
de port cros seul endroit protégé
donc imaginez vous dans un seul endroit
protégé on trouve énormément de
plastique
imaginez vous à 103 qui sont pas
protégés voilà c'est l'homme des
pratiques à la dérive
même si des principes au fond est-ce que
c'était difficile à réaliser
alors pour moi physiquement la partie la
plus difficile c'est le cheville parce
que je le fais avec une monopalme et
c'est pas facile de garder pendant
quatre heures pendant cinq heures des
nages les mono palme dans les pieds
pendant tout ce temps dans les pieds ça
gonfle ses sens et c'est très difficile
à vivre la chimie au lycée souffle ça va
je n'étais pas fatigué même si j'ai pas
eu la possibilité mais préparés parce
que dieu confinement toute la
préparation qui est fait en dehors de
l'oaciq qu'après il faut mieux la g50
100 km même si effet plus parce que
c'était plus souvent s'ils disaient
qu'on nage pas tout de loi on me met au
niveau physique cela était sale est ce
que vous étiez quand même entraîné un
petit peu avant de partir deux autres
fois en piscine les restes c'était une
fois au maire et au malawi et j'ai eu
beaucoup d'envolées pied un plan plan
des blessures
j'ai eu un mois et demi ainsi qu'à 10 et
les pieds donc pas pu m'entraîner au
maire la plupart du temps de monsieur
besson en vélo et courses on l'appelait
ou sinon je fais des squats
on a mené la course à pied ou d'apnée
mais comme à new york ont fait deux
morts alors vous l'avez dire vous n'êtes
plus un habitude
de la nage en piscine de l'avenir en
piscine est ce que c'est vraiment plus
compliqué de le faire en mer alors je
société petite des marges ambulance
c'est plus difficile parce qu'il n'y a
pas les mêmes repères à la piscine on en
profondeur dans lequel on peut pas
effacer à la mer
la profondeur idéal cédait 2 m mais des
fois par manque de repères je me
trouvais à cinq mètres de profondeur des
fois il fallait de loi mais je suis un
kayak et les cartes n'avaient pas de loi
donc c'est plus compliqué à homer qui
est en piscine mais c'est ainsi plus de
chats reach est là la récompense
c'était le premier jour des neiges ya
trois ans dauphins sauvages et les
défenses et de belles rencontres
il a nagé avec moi pendant deux trois
minutes c'était super et après ali d or
qu on a trouvé des mérous des idées
beaucoup aimé du souci donc si vous
voulez c'est plus naturel de le faire
aux moeurs qui est à la piscine voilà je
préfère vous avez collecté au total
combien de kilos de déchets je ne peux
pas vous dire je pense qu'ils ont au
total 4 est-ce que vous pensez que cette
action ce que vous avez fait va
interpeller le grand public
oui notamment on a fait avec d'autres
associations et explore en préserve
projet assure protège ta mère est plus
addiction et il a récolté beaucoup de
déchets 1 sur facebook on assume
cagnotte
et ces cagnottes a mis notre projet dans
les meilleurs quatrièmes places et et
les compagnies cotées plus d'argent si
on gagne c'est un canyon et l'argent
récolté va être donné à tous et sociaux
qui participent à d'autres projets pour
nettoyer le sang donc je pense que
l'action qu'on a fait pour la journée
mondiale d'action et s'arrête pas là et
continuera dans tout projet et non 200 m
justement plat pour la portable pour la
même cause de nettoyons et sensibiliser
les gens à rien jeter à la mer à
consommer autrement et apporte de gérer
leur service
l'avis d'intention
alors vous êtes un habitué un des défis
on dit depuis tout à l'heure vous avez
notamment réalisé des séances d'apnée a
habillé en dauphin par exemple est ce
qu'il y aura à la piscine de saint cyr
l'école je le précise
est ce qu'il y aura d'autres événements
de ce type dans les prochains mois les
prochaines années à saint cyr l'école
est ce que vous avez d'autres projets en
tête
alors je ne peux pas vous dire si c'est
associé à l'école ou ailleurs
mais il doit toujours des projets c'est
ce que j'ai pour l'avant-poste
sensibiliser et d'éduquer
avec notre accent les nouvelles
générations et de les indiquer à
consommer autrement à protéger le milieu
aquatique a prêté protéger et préserver
la vie sauvage sous la planète
et voilà mon objectif donc il y aura
d'autres projets associés à l'école ou
ailleurs mais toujours pour la bonne
cause bonjour merci à vous andré
cabreira villa merci d'être intervenu
dans cette émission continuera
évidemment vous suivre dans les
prochaines années sur vos prochains
défis nous allons maintenant prendre la
direction de chatou la ville va
accueillir le 18 juillet prochain
la dernière étape du tour de france 2021
pour faire monter l'effervescence dans
la commune un événement autour du vélo a
été organisée sur deux jours sur l'île
des impressionnistes
au programme de cette fête du tour du
vélo smoothie les tests de vélos
originaux des parcours pour les tout
petits des sceaux sur coussins
gonflables et des sensibilisations sur
le vélo adapté au total près de dix
mille personnes en profiter à ses
activités
on écoute l'une des coordinatrices c'est
de rappeler que les yvelines est
vraiment une terre de vélo fin on
accueille d'événements beaucoup
d'événements sportifs nationaux enfin on
développe beaucoup de vélo route aussi
sur le sur le territoire donc on a cet
aspect loisirs tourisme sportif
événementiel donc c'est un petit peu de
rappeler tout ça et de faire beaucoup
profité tous les to les yvelinois et
même les franciliens de façon plus large
si vous êtes un passionné de sports de
combat ce rendez vous est à noter dans
vos agendas gala de mma arts martiaux
mixtes est organisée ce samedi 10
juillet à partir de 20h30 os des ciels
center de maurepas le rendez vous est à
huis clos mais il vous sera possible de
voir la dizaine de combats
a programmé via internet en direct les
matchs seront diffusés sur fight tirer
nation un point com enfin on termine par
du baseball les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux se déplaceront ce week-end
sur le terrain du stade toulousain
victoire impérative pour les inimités 1
qui sont un peu à la peine depuis le
début de la saison en première division
les yvelinois ont pour l'instant un
bilan de deux victoires et quatre
défaites en six matches et ils sont
troisièmes de leur poule
le stade toulousain affiche le même
bilan ils joueront à partir de 11 heures
sur le stade qu'en dit nelson de
toulouse c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]
m